pour 38 contre 34 et donc les
amendements de suppression sont adoptés
en conséquence l'article premier est
supprimé la commission s'oppose à une
abrogation de la réforme des retraites
au cours d'une discussion houleuse
non pas la peine de dire que vous avez
un bel organe vocal j'en ai un aussi
donc vous voyez
qu'une réponse l'obstruction ouvrez les
chakras on se calme le déni de
démocratie continue
alors si on veut bloquer complètement
politiquement et socialement ce pays et
bien que la minorité présidentielle
continue ses manœuvres l'objectif étant
surtout pas de vote sur l'article
premier pour cette raison là notre rôle
de parlementaire ne sert plus à
grand-chose nous le constatons et donc
nous partons
la parole est Charles de Courson a déjà
prévenu il déposera un amendement pour
le rétablir mais la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale aura alors le
pouvoir de le déclarer il receva c'est
une petite phrase qui sonne comme un
camouflet une petite phrase prononcée
hier par le président en Conseil des
ministres
le combat contre l'extrême droite ne
passe plus par des arguments moraux on
n'arrivera pas à faire croire à des
millions de Français qui ont voté pour
elle que ce sont des fascistes d'abord
parce que c'est extrême droite s'est
transformé et ensuite parce qu'elle a
beaucoup d'électeurs aujourd'hui qui ne
votent pas pour cette histoire mais
votre parce qu'ils se disent au fond on
n'a pas encore réessayer cela et ce qui
nous propose par essais de visant combat
patte cette façon là et c'est vrai
notamment que dans la région des Hauts
de France on les a même fait reculer par
des résultats en sortant les gens de la
misère en baissant le niveau de la
colère on les a fait reculés
et un ministre deux jours plus tôt
prononcé ces mots à la radio quand on
est premier ministre de la République
française on ne se comporte pas comme un
chef de gang je pense que ces propos
sont pitoyables qui sont extrêmement
graves quand vous êtes désavoués comme
ça par le Président de la République
c'est un désaveu comme il y en a pas eu
depuis très longtemps sur un premier
ministre c'est qu'à mon avis ça sent un
peu la fin de votre relation ça sent un
peu la fin de votre couple et je pense
qu'en fait c'est une dame sur le départ
je pense qu'elle disparaîtra aussi vite
qu'elle est apparue dans l'histoire de
la Cinquième République c'est ce que
j'ai pu entendre sur madame la Première
ministre je veux ici lui redire toute ma
confiance la portière du véhicule garée
sur un parking c'est refermé sur
l'animal alors qu'il cherchait de la
nourriture regardez les agents ont
attaché une longue corde autour de la
poignée afin de pouvoir ouvrir la porte
à distance en toute sécurité dans les
rayons de nos supermarchés les prix
commencent légèrement à baisser
l'inflation honnêtement ralentit en mer
en 5,1% sur un an toujours indiqué avec
le gouvernement que à l'entrée de l'été
nous verrions l'inflation ralentir nous
y sommes l'inflation ralentie et il y a
un certain nombre de prix qui vont
commencer à baisser les prix du café de
l'huile et de la viande ABC par rapport
au mois dernier ce des chips des
biscuits et des céréales stagnent en
revanche les prix des produits frais
comme le poisson les fruits et légumes
continuent d'augmenter
voilà vous voyez l'ours s'enfuir du
véhicule
et vous noterez en tous les cas voilà
l'intérieur du véhicule entièrement
déchiqueté soit les grands industriels
tiennent leurs engagements dans les
jours qui viennent soit j'utiliserai
l'instrument fiscal pour récupérer les
marges qui doivent rendre au
consommateur